hey guys Pete peppers here I'm gonna do
something a little bit different today
the huge game at the Thrones fan so I'm
going to go I was actually going back to
watch this vision of the past that brand
has in season 6 episode 6 where he is
leaving the weirwood the heart tree
where the children of the forest were
and mirrors dragging them away in the
snow and he's still sort of ingesting
the information that the three-eyed
Raven gave them it happens in a flash
there's a bunch of cool stuff that you
can see but I wanted to break it down a
little bit closer so I figured that make
a video of it so this is will have a lot
of spoilers in it obviously if you
haven't been watching this season and
this is what the first part of it looks
like in regular speed you know you get
an idea you see him falling you see the
White Walkers you see Mad King Aerys
there and you see his father let's slow
it down
and let's look at it sort of piece by
piece
alright so the first thing we see are
the pyromancers below below the ground
here in King's Landing and they are
working on wildfire and we see there's
no real indication as far as I can tell
when this was if this is in the past or
if this is in the present but we've you
know even if you never read the books
here from the earth wildfire from
earlier in the series when Tyrion uses
the wildfire that Cersei started making
to help out in the battle a black fire
or black water sorry then
after that we see a quick glimpse of a
dragon and you can also see that it's
it's over King's Landing or it appears
to be over King's Landing again we don't
know if this is past present or future
but just in the dialogue of the show it
kind of seems like it's probably in the
near future then we see Mad King Aerys
this would be if you know if you never
read the book my King Aerys was the King
that Robert Baratheon took the throne
from and Jaime Lannister the reason why
he's called the kingslayer's because he
killed it killed King Aerys Targaryen
and Aerys Targaryen is also the nurses
father so we see a quick shot of him and
he's upset
they call him the Mad King for a reason
he used the Wildfire to do a lot of
damage around the city and on the on his
own own people then we see the night's
king he is go back for a second he's
sort of doing his lift in his arms thing
where he brings all the wildlings X's
whites and then we got a quick view of
this character whose name I don't
remember but she was the likeable
wildling that decided that she was going
to go with Jon Snow but when the battle
happened she couldn't fight the children
the whites that were kids so she ended
up becoming the White herself when they
tore apart so I think that was just sort
of a thing of like even characters you
like can end up being mindless White's
that are controlled by the night's king
and the other White Walkers so then we
see brand fall but what I thought about
was interesting about this was Branson
doesn't remember you know falling and
it's it shows him fall what she knows he
did but it doesn't have any indication
as to why what he you know what he was
up there doing what he saw which is
really more important as far as as
things go so we don't we you know he he
sees his own fall but he doesn't have
any kind of revelation towards the fact
that Jaime Lannister is the one that
pushed him down because he saw them
sleeping together so then we see the Sun
coming up over the frozen landscape here
it's notable I guess because it's dark
and you see the Sun rising could also
mean like you know we're shining in the
coming of winter so on and so forth
there's a lot of it could be going on
there and then Fran sees his own mother
get her throat slit we see the dragon
again dragon flying and landing and then
we see Daenerys from the first season
when she came from the firepower Drogo's
funeral pyre unscathed unburnt with the
hatch dragon on her shoulder and then we
see the night's king the first time we
saw him taking one Craster's babies to
become be turned into a white Walker and
this little ceremony scene that we had
from before there's the new white Walker
dragon again
Mad King Aerys again night's king again
dragon dragon baby white Walker and then
we have Eddard Stark as a man grown down
at King's Landing about to get his head
chopped off for treason after he
basically tried to let everyone know
that Joffrey and Tommen were bastards
from incense from incest from Jaime I
mean from Searcy and Jaime having a
child alright so then we skip ahead to
his next sequence we'll watch it that's
how quick some of the same energy some
of its a little bit more more complete
and then we have other scenes as well so
we'll look at it frame by frame in one
second alright so what we have here we
have starts out again with the Sun
rising over the frozen landscape and
again we get the dragon flash in the
King's Landing flash another another
shot at Daenerys another shot of
Craster's baby and the night's king
tournament I Walker and then we see a
bunch of crows or Ravens whatever you
want to call them and this and it's a
lot of them it kind of reminds me for
book readers he reminds me of cold hands
and his crows
um here there's no real context it's
just grows and then we see the roots of
the where woods which could be an
indication or where this comes from or
just the fact that there's more to that
I mean there's definitely a lot more to
that in the underlying thing we don't
know how much we'll see about that in
the show but then we see the pyromancers
again filling in jars with wildfire no
real idea of whether it's in the past or
present or even in the future but they
got a cool looking bottle that they keep
it in and then we got Mad King Aerys
again and this is the scene where he
screams from the Iron Throne
burn them all and then we see this this
is uh one of the more interesting clips
this is not something we saw on the show
before and it is wildfire destroying
what looks like the area where they were
storing all this wildfire so I'm not
really sure what that is
could be could be a big disaster that
happens could be a future situation
where the you know where someone in
King's Landing uses the stocks of
wildfire to destroy it or it could even
be like what would have happened if the
Mad King had his way and this didn't
happen and this is Jamie as you know in
his role as the Kings hand or not the
King to him at the Kingsguard he was
guarding Aerys
whenever the Lannisters came to the city
the Mad King wanted him to kill his own
father and was you know going off about
like let's burn everybody let's you know
basically burn all of my enemies which
is pretty much everybody at this point
and
dad Jamie became the Kingslayer by
breaking his oath to protect the king
and pulling his sword then we got young
Ned young Ned during Robert's rebellion
at the Tower of joy we saw some
flashbacks of this if you read the books
you know the the dream that he has that
haunts him that comes from this period
of time and he says where's my sister
and then we see this scene where that
looks like his hand based on the buddies
wearing blood it's apparently inside the
Tower of joy
that's a sister Lee Anna's body and her
hand and blood which would be most
likely for all intents and purposes and
there's really not another alternate
theory here but she just gave birth and
as a result she dies asked Ned to do
something to promise her something and
then we see his bloody hand with the
sisters blood turned into a fist and
then we see Jamie stabbing Mad King in
his back and killing the last Targaryen
King see Rob getting stabbed by Roose
Bolton we see the King die see another
sequence of the crow and we see Rob fall
to the ground that happened at the red
wedding obviously in the fray when the
phrase betrayed and north and then we
see leaf making the first white white
Walker from the last episode
and then we see one of the white walkers
this isn't a white this is an actual
white Walker one of the others the
counsel of the king when he is coming
after Jon Snow from the hardhome scene
and Jon finding Longclaw
which he had dropped or in the fight
fight and obviously the blaring steel
turns out to negate the magic that the
White Walkers have and then we see Jaime
Lannister sitting on the Iron Throne
which you know from the books is where
they found him after he count killed the
king and another shot of this wildfire
explosion another another quick shot of
the dragon another quick shot of that
Daenerys with baby dragon baby white
Walker and crows Leafs Mad King
wildfire is cool because it's green and
that's that one alright so now we go to
the next one
and this one is this is what it looks
like in little speed regular speed a lot
of hardhome stuff a lot of whites images
of the whites and then we see the whites
and the woods are closing in on him and
Mira and look at it frame by frame so so
he falls again we've seen that one
repeated several times and then we see
the Pyromancer so if there's something
going to go happen something important
happening with wildfire obviously brands
falling was important for several
reasons and yeah the Mad King I see him
again but what does it mean you know
it's hard to say he's really not that
important to the show at this point
since you know we don't really go into
prehistory so you know I don't know you
guys could tell me what you think in the
comments of why they're showing that in
relation to everything else I mean the
other stuff like his fall and after the
pyromancers alchemist kill we see you
know the whites the whites obviously are
a real threat for the future but not
sure like you know Mad King is except
for maybe it's also foreshadowing the
fact that wildfire wildfire is gonna
play a big part of this confrontation
that's coming up
between the others and man and that
would also include children of the
forest and everybody else because you
know if it's anything like the the long
night and you know we'll have to see but
yeah again see him rising you know
bringing the dead back to life has
White's to fight in his army that's
there they're saying bran looks at the
army that's a flashback from when he
first went to my first one into the
weirwood net without supervision from
the Bloodraven again the the whites
charging the stronghold at hardhome
coming through the wall another look at
how they're dead but they're not
decaying and obviously the thing about
hardhome is is when these whites came
they exponentially increased the number
of whites in the army because they
killed everybody that was there all the
wildlings that were holed up there
trying to decide what to do this is that
awesome scene where they all come flying
down over the mountain just showing the
resilience and just how they don't
really they can do things that make them
really hard to destroy you know they can
fall from distance and then we see the
whites closing in on branimir again in
real time
he still uses where he starts to wake up
a little bit another picture of the
night's king with his newly formed or
newly grown army you know that just got
a whole lot bigger like I was saying and
that was a great team I guess that
really kind of goes on for a while the
wall and here was those children that
kid whites children that were that were
killed that turned into whites that took
out the likable character here is the
reanimated horse that night's king and
the other white walkers ride around on
their dead horses don't live beyond the
wall so you know whatever that's just a
well they're not you know they don't
they don't hang out and just you know
it's a it's a really wildlings don't
ride horses let's put it that way not
the normal everyday ones picture of the
people coming back to life and back to
the whites and bran
one more little flash here right before
he wakes up see the whites in regular
time and then some ominous footage of
what we have in store perhaps so we'll
look at this real quick and then that'll
be that so
here we have flash of the wall coming
down just so really the fact that
nothing is safe that's what that's what
it makes me think about like nothing
it's safe once this power is unleashed
kids aren't safe
our heroes aren't safe you see John
they're looking at the night everything
turns to chaos and this this is from the
I'm not seen I think it is it's from the
scene that you know one of the very
first scenes where we saw the White
Walkers where they're marching with
their army looking pretty looking pretty
tough the night's king checking out is
battle above
home
another of the the wild Walker's in
their army traveling across the icy
field and then the climactic ending of
it all this is from brands we would trip
like I said where he went without the
Bloodraven and he saw the the whites and
the area where the first white Walker
was created and the night's king is sort
of right there and before brand knows
what's going on he reaches out and he
marks them and this is what led to them
being able to break the the spell around
the the tree and be able to enter in and
destroy everything inside and kill
everybody including the children and
Hodor
so there's that
there's the met that is the mark and
that ends the sequence and when they go
back and then of course you probably
watch the rest of the episode and saw
what happened so what do you think it
means um obviously a lot of repeated
imagery Fire Dragons wildfire the
history you see a lot of the you know
what's happened to brands family up into
this point you see Daenerys
being reborn with her dragons and that
dragon flying over Westeros and King's
Landing in particular so a lot of stuff
why is it important we don't really know
but I think it was pretty interesting
like I said I don't usually make Game of
Thrones videos I watch a lot of them and
I'm a big fan but I just wanted to I
wanted to look at this scene and break
it down so I thought I would I'd be
happy to share some insights and
thoughts in the comments if you leave
questions I'm a big fan of both the
books and the shows so check it out
tell me what you think give the video a
like and subscribe to my channel talk to
you soon